so we hear so much about the business of
bliss and monetizing your passion but at
the same time my job as a job yeah and
at some point everything's where it
becomes routine and I heard a great
interview with Kurt Cobain one time and
he said he wished he could be in a band
for two years and then right as it was
about to take off leave it right the fun
part was in the building it right so
what happens when we go through a
creative burnout when yes it's fun to
create you all that but becomes a job we
now have people to answer to
we're paying on our mortgage or whatever
what happens to that creative burnout
like how do you renew is it time to go
to new direction
well sometimes I really never counseled
people to quit their jobs especially in
today's economy it's like actually and I
think there's a really rational model
where people can have day jobs and night
jobs or a job where you're paying the
rent another and then you go home and
you do other stuff or sometimes when
when I work with people who are
screenwriters they do one for them one
for me one for them one for me and that
way they keep their soul alive so one
big studio gig one little movie that may
never get made but I really want to
write one big studio gig one movie for
me and I think that's kind of of a fair
and rational model because you know you
do learn things from being in that
interaction with those bosses or those
studios or those big media companies you
I think it does up your game I think it
sharpens your skills it teaches you
skills that you may need just to get
your movie may may teach you
presentation skills it might teach you
how to get up in front of a board room
of 50 people and not have them make
snarky comments after 30 seconds and
that might be an amazing skill that you
need to learn when you're pitching
investors around the table at Sundance
one morning so
so I think I think that's good that you
have to do that she was a creative
burnout what I see people do is reinvent
themselves I think that we are we always
have to be in a state of reinvention of
seeing the world with fresh eyes and
turning ourselves inside out to do that
and we have to be willing to unlearn and
try new things look most people in
today's world are not going to have one
career I probably had four or five
careers most people who are graduating
from college now will probably have
eight or nine careers in their work life
also because they will be working until
they are probably 75 or 80 and when I
see different careers I don't mean just
like a thing and they shift a little bit
to the right or the left and they're
just in this constant you know clear
track what I mean is that they are going
to have wholly different careers so what
are the skills that we need to be ready
for this world we need the skills of
collaboration communication visual media
skills and these are transferable across
you know all areas people are in
technology for example the training
technology from the point they start
freshman year the technology they
learned in freshman year is obsolete by
the time they graduate senior year right
so learning you know mastering a certain
software has a diminishing value
mastering how to master software has
incredible value because that's the
transferable skill
you